what's going on reject nation we're
gonna watch today
from marvel marvel 616
official trailer for disney plus
i don't know it's marvel so you gotta
watch it cause marvel marvel marvel
marvel
stan always said that the marvel
universe is the world outside your
window
and the people can find characters they
could see themselves in
bringing a piece of art to life is
difficult to not put yourself into
the work docu series
[Music]
knock your shots off yeah
that guy's a great writer people really
believe women weren't reading comics
that
inspired us to do more
cosplay oh this is so cool i love this
this is really cool nobody else had ever
done this before
fearless storytellers i killed spiderman
what that's insane
it's a collection of stage plays written
for high school
[Music]
i never thought i could make a living
the drawing spiderman is totally
different
yes japanese spider-man drain on
[Music]
it's about how we we became who we are
it's about us about the influence and
innovation
culture was impacted by the greatness of
marble
nerds everywhere were galvanized the
movies made a big part of it especially
in today's culture
but i love that they're really going
back to the historical roots man i wish
stan lee was in this
ah i mean they probably had they'd have
to have some archival footage at the
very least i mean i imagine they shot
this after his passing though
so yeah of course it'll be some archival
footage but
i i think i saw my notifications and
they went up for cosmic wonder
uh in regards to this video and so i
feel like he'll probably have a little
bit more insight so
i kind of want to watch what he has to
say how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and today
marvel released their marvel 616
official trailer
now this is actually going to be a very
exciting new series coming to disney
plus and hopefully a very
impactful one to our community marvel
616 is going to be about how comic book
characters and of course comic books
influenced people in their real lives so
the show is essentially about our
community
it's about us and i'll break down what
exactly we're going to see
in this new disney plus series including
what to expect from each
episode and this is confirmed to be
eight episodes long
so to start off with its title it's kind
of funny because they call it marvel
616.
earth 616 is the main wonderful universe
where everything really takes i got that
but
used to show the marvel universe
universe a multiverse which is what this
show is about
what marvel's place is in our world so
episode one
is quite possibly going to be one of the
coolest episodes ever it's going to be
about japanese
spidey this is something that happens
or even seen in 1978 marvel struck a
deal with japanese tv giant
to adapt the company's most popular
superhero for japanese audiences
now this spider-man is something that
we've never really seen before here in
the us it involved a really giant robot
a really cool car but most importantly
it became a really
important influence on japanese pop
culture and this first episode is going
to tell the story and show
footage of japanese spider-man that
probably a lot of people haven't seen
before
the second episode is titled higher
further faster and it's going to be
directed by gillian jacobs from the show
community
that the russo brothers directed and
it's going to introduce the viewers to
women who have played important roles in
marvel's history
the third episode is titled amazing
artisans and it's going to focus on two
international marvel artists javier
garonne and natasha bustos who live
in barcelona and use their life
experiences to influence their work on
popular young superheroes like miles
morales and
moon girl episode 4 is titled lost and
found and this is going to be kind of an
interesting episode because they're
going to explore the most
obscure the most wild and forgotten
marvel characters
the fifth episode is actually pretty
cool it's titled suit up and it's going
to be about
cosplay specifically it's going to be
about interviews with cosplayers and
people who are attending new york comic
con for the very first time so if you're
wondering what new york comic con is
like or you're trying to get your taste
of it since it's been canceled this year
this episode is for you yes nycc is
still online
go to it and walk around and dress up
like you normally do episode 6 is
titled unboxed and is actually going to
go over the relationship between comics
and toys and they're going to explore
when
and how sometimes toys influence the
comics and comics influence the toys
and a lot of you will like this they'll
be going over marvel's funko
really fascinating series the marvel
method and it's going to take a close
look at the creation of the new iron man
2020 comic they're also going to show us
the historical background and
development
on the marvel method as it was created
by stan lee and jack kirby
and the last episode the eighth episode
is titled
marvel spotlight now it's interesting
because this is going to be directed by
alison brie
so as it turns out she was meeting with
marvel about a project it just wasn't
shielded
but it's going to follow a group of
students at florida's
high schools they put on a performance
of the new marvel spotlight plays and
they'll talk about just how much the
marvel characters mean to them
and influence them in everyday life and
that's what we're going to get from this
new series
no it's not a series connected to the
mcu but it's a real life series it's
about how marvel affects
us our community so it's going to be a
pretty cool show i'm definitely watching
it and i hope everybody else enjoys it
as well
this comes out on december 20th on
disney plus so let me know in the
comments down below if you were going to
be watching it
of course i'm still doing my funko pop
giveaway this week we're giving away a
cyclops funko pop all you got to do to
enter a subscribe like this video and
leave a comment down below for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof
that was really informative that was
more informative than the trailer
the clear bridge is his entire series
oh that's what every episode's gonna
entail where'd you find all that
information this is just on their
website is there is there a press
release
did you read the press yeah i i totally
missed all that i love that japanese
spider-man's getting an opportunity to
really shine
finally he's slowly been creeping his
way back into the spotlight
ever since you know italian spider-man
became the meme that it is i think it's
inspired people to look outside of the
states
well i think with that i remember honest
trailers did japanese spider-man along
uh i think sometime last year two years
ago now we gotta get japanese spider-man
included into the next into the spider
verse dude it's gonna it'll happen this
the thing if this really puts it back
into the cultural
consciousness but i think it's weird
that they're actually starting with
japanese spider-man maybe because that's
is that like the first live-action
adaptation or something like that
they've ever done
of spider-man i mean yeah he's a beloved
character he's spider-man so i think
that makes sense to start off with
because everything else that they said
of
the trajectory of what this documentary
series will do kind of just makes a lot
more sense to me in that order
of how it starts like way in the past to
come into today but the beginning is
japanese spider-man it just seems a
little odd yeah it's a very
nice show about the breath of the marvel
you know comic book everything universe
yeah but i like that they're going to be
exploring
more this seems to be going into the
effect marvel has had
ultimately and beyond even just marvel
just in terms of comic book mediums and
how it's influenced
culture and going into like they said
about the women who were reading comics
and how
they seemed like they didn't have a
voice in comics you can't do one of
these without
exploring the levels of cosplay which
weirdly seems like the least
interesting one to me because there's
been so much exposed about it and it's
been so heavily featured
through so much media now that yeah
there's not as much of a mystery behind
it although i'm sure they can come up
with a cool angle about it you know i
imagine so
but what i also really appreciated and
i'm sure the cosplay one will have more
of the movie inclusion
side of it this doesn't seem like it's
only riffing on the mcu films to remind
you about the
mcu movies this is mainly about the
creation of the characters and how it's
influenced
us and i think that's actually a really
beautiful approach to take
for this series as opposed to like
yeah i know i've seen all the behind the
scenes on the movies i know how
impactful they are i get it
you know but this actually seems
different and i'm glad this trailer has
so many views too
yeah uh because it's not one of their
you know disney plus original shows like
one division
or something it's it is a disney plus
original series but it's
very much a documentary like but i
wonder how many people clicked on it
thinking it was going to be something
different
easter eggs yeah
that does seem like a really cool aspect
to it is that it seems like it's going
to be focusing in on the people who have
been
shaped by and then have helped to shape
the marvel universe
getting profiles on specific artists and
things like that and yeah especially
like
the women who were you know finally
incorporated and we're able to you know
guide some of the creative side of this
like that stuff feels very interesting
because also you can trace history back
that way too you know i'm sure that
there are historical moments of you know
certain writers being hired and
affecting certain story lines and stuff
like that and that seems like a really
cool thing to explore here as well
seems very human and very alive i just
think the one thing that was kind of
missing for me to make this a little bit
more compelling
everything seems about celebration and i
don't know how much celebration of eight
episodes i could watch i need something
that represents some type of dramatic
stakes
something that represents certain
obstacles i had to overcome
you know like you can't make women
characters or something you know
you gotta have that or what you killed
spider-man you can't do that like really
explore the drama
and going against the grain of things
something that represents some edge
because right now this all feels very
celebratory which is
appropriate and fine uh i i just feel
like if i'm gonna commit to eight
episodes i'd want it to be more than
just
yay i wanna want some of those steaks in
there somewhere
you don't want it to be a fluff piece
you want it to actually have some kind
of
meat on its bones that's enriching to
watch not just like oh yeah i like
marvel too
yeah yeah all right guys well what do
you think about this are you excited for
marvel 616 leave your thoughts down
below thanks warren for putting together
that extra piece of info that really
broke everything down
subscribe to the real reject subscribe
to constant wonder while you're at it
too
click that notification bell last but
not least patron of the day
shout out
pete dawn pete dunn you are our last
patron of the day this month and i just
wanted to give you some love
because if anyone brings a little light
into our lives and this is a
show that's all about exploring the
light that has been shed by marvel
you're that hero for us i want to hope
that you feel appreciated and loved this
month
and every month but especially this
month because you know
we're cresting from the hot sweltering
burnt up summer into what's hopefully
maybe a better fall
and it's a dawn of a new day i'm just
thinking about you and hoping you're
well
and uh yeah much love buddy take care
[Music]
buddy